hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in number 31 of his introductory
lectures on psychoanalysis the one
entitled the dissection of the psychical
personality
one of the key ideas that sigmund freud
is explaining to his audience
is that of what he calls the super ego
the uber ich
the part of ourselves according to
freudian psychology
which has a number of important
functions
most of which tend to make us unhappy
and which we can't completely
escape from but we can at least
understand now he's not you know
originating his concept here in these
lectures he's been working with us for a
very long time but he's trying to
explain it
in as clear and as
basic a way as possible the first
mention of it without actually using the
term
comes in when he talks about patients
suffering from delusions
of being observed they complain to us
that perpetually
they are being molested by the
observation of unknown powers presumably
persons
and they may come with you know auditory
hallucinations
so he says how would it be
if these insane people were right if in
each of us there is present in his ego
an agency like this which observes
and threatens to punish and which in
them has merely
become sharply divided from their ego
and mistakenly displaced into external
reality so he's saying that this is not
the case for all of us but it but
something like this
might be going on there's external
reality as opposed to the
the you the me the we that is the ego
and part of the ego has been projected
out there
instead although that can be the case
for us in unusual circumstances
instead we've got a part of our own ego
that has
you know if we want to use his
crystalline uh
metaphor it's it's fractured forth
outside of ourselves but still within
us so we don't hear voices coming from
outside instead we hear the voice of
a term that he's going to use conscience
telling us you shouldn't have done that
that was wrong you're a dirty dirty
animal
or whatever else you want to imagine
right
so he talks about this agency
that observes and threatens to punish
and that is what is going to be
the super ego he tells us
i formed the idea the separation of the
observing agency from the rest of the
ego
might be a regular feature of the ego's
structure and that idea has never left
me
i was driven to investigate the further
characteristics and connections the
agency
which was thus separated off so
the superego is not you might say part
of our
original equipment right there
in the psyche as it's you know created
when a child
is born and develops no it's it's
something that develops out of
the ego and it's there's a sign
a bit of progress here right um
we need to develop a super ego in
certain respects in order to be
normal progressing developing properly
but it's also
something that we misrecognize
as a result and a little bit early on
in this he says this agency
must be what we call our conscience
he's actually going to you know rebut
this in a moment there is scarcely
anything
in us that we so regularly separate from
our ego and so
easily set over against it as precisely
our conscience i feel an inclination to
do something
i think will give me pleasure but i
abandon it on the ground
that my conscience does not allow it or
i've let myself be persuaded
by too great an expectation of pleasure
into doing something which
to something to which the voice of
conscience has objected and after the
deed
my conscience punishes me with
distressing reproaches
and causes me to feel remorse for the
deed so we often think of our conscience
as something within us which isn't the
same thing as the us that
does the action that chooses that
thinks through what's going on you know
you think about the old-fashioned
cartoon
way of portraying this where you've got
an angel on one shoulder
and you got a devil on the other
shoulder that's conscience
and then you know the opposite of
conscience the parts of you that are
saying no no go ahead and eat the cake
go ahead and you know look at the thing
you're not supposed to look at go ahead
and break the promise
and then conscience is like no no you
shouldn't do that
and who do we listen to the angel or the
devil well that determines what we're
doing
in more recent cartoons like that a
family guy both the angel and the devil
are equally stupid and venial
and so you know a character like peter
can't do much of anything but in the
older cartoons there's a stark contrast
right
and then you've got the tortured person
wavering
between them that would be the ego
so freud says maybe this this thing is
conscience and he says no that's the
wrong way to look at this
because conscience is only one of the
functions
of this whatever we're going to call it
this agency
he called that he calls the super ego
he tells us it's more prudent to keep
the agency as something independent
and a supposed conscience is one of its
functions
and that self-observation which is an
essential preliminary to the judging
activity of conscience is another uh
function so
conscience judges but only after
the superego has already looked at
things looked at what the ego
is doing a little bit later
he tells us some other important
things about the this notion
or this this agency of the
super ego he's going to tell us that it
it has a certain autonomy
in relation to the ego
meaning that it can operate on its own
it doesn't have to wait for the ego
to get itself into a situation it can
plan out the situation in advance and
say you must do things this way and this
way
and not do those sorts of things um
he also talks about it following its own
intentions which is another important
aspect of it once it's once it's got its
own
we could say its own driving
force it's able to make
intentions orientations directions for
itself so if for example
if it's tied together with worries about
cleanliness and uncleanliness
it can tell you you need to go and wash
your hands you filthy pig
or however else that's going to frame
itself or don't touch
that person because they're dirty you
don't enter into these
sort of situations the other aspect
that's really important
as well as he says that it's independent
of the ego
for the energy that it it draws
upon so even if the ego is we could say
fatigued or
worn out or wavering or
indecisive the superego itself
can have an energy that carries it
through
independent of the ego which it
originally
derived from so this is a
you know a set of very important
features
freud talks about three main
functions here in this essay
one of self-observation that we've
already talked about right so
self-observation
is the ego originally observing itself
which then becomes the superego
observing the ego
conscience judging itself usually quite
harshly
as freud is going to point out in in
this
you know the super ego in part also
derives from the parental function
but it only takes the judginess the
meanness the sternness
the cruelty it doesn't take the love the
affirmation
or any of those sorts of things instead
it's it's kind of you know just the mean
side right and then this thing that that
he calls
the ideal which we're going to get to
in a moment it has a function
of the ideal you can you can say or
i mean that's the german foreign
maintaining the ideal is another way
that gets translated
here um so he tells us that this is you
know a very important
agency now he's got a really interesting
discussion
there about melancholic attacks
this is not a language that we use too
much
in the present we tend to think about
melancholy as somebody being just
sad being blue but this is actually a
term that goes way way back in medicine
all the way to the greeks
melancholis you know the
black bile that was supposed to produce
not just
sadness but also remorse also
anger even rage things like that
melancholy people are not just the ones
sitting around
graveyards you know whining and crying
or anything like that
they might be picking up the grave and
you know stoner throwing at you
so what freud is calling a melancholic
attack
it's not just being sad
it's where you feel that there's there's
things that you've done that are
um you know screwed up that you have
uh made a mess out of things so here
here we go he says
hardly have we familiarized ourselves
with the idea of a super ego
like this which as we've pointed out
enjoys a certain degree of autonomy etc
etc
and he says that a clinical picture
forces itself on our notice which throws
a striking light on the severity of its
agency
and indeed its cruelty and its changing
relations to the ego
i am thinking of the condition of
melancholia or
more precisely of melancholic attacks
which you two will have heard
plenty about even if you're not
psychiatrists and there's a footnote
here from
from strakey the um the translator who
says
modern terminology would probably speak
of depression and that's that's quite
right
but there could be there could be other
manifestations of this than than just
what we typically call depression
what is the what is the the problematic
here he says
the most striking feature of this
illness is the way in which the super
ego
treats the ego while a melancholic can
like other people
show a greater or lesser degree of
severity to himself in his healthy
periods
during a melancholic attack his superego
becomes
over severe abuses the poor ego
humiliates it and ill treats it
threatens it with the direst punishments
reproaches it for actions in the
remotest past which had taken
lightly which had been taken lightly at
the time as though it had spent the
whole
interval in collecting accusations that
had only been waiting for its present
access of strength
in order to bring them up and make a
condemnatory judgment
on their basis right so a very long
discussion there
what is freud saying the super ego has
like
hoarded up these memories of all the
ways in which you have screwed
up melancholic person and it's going to
lay them out for you
so you can think them over in the middle
of the night or
while you're trying to do work or while
you're trying to eat or make love or do
whatever else
and you're going to get not just you
know flashes of these
you're going to feel like crap about it
because the superego is going to show
you exactly
what you are it's doing so
through its faculty of judging right
he goes on and says it applies the
strictest moral standard
to the helpless ego which is at its
mercy
and this is quite interesting right the
superego
can kind of respond but its responses
are the way poor freud portrays it
ineffective
against the the ego can respond to the
super ego
but it's not a very effective response
that's part of what you know
psychoanalysis is supposed to help out
with
you might say defending to some degree
the
super ego tr helping you to figure out
how to
respond to it and you know if we wanted
to switch into different modalities
we might say that this is like the
negative self-talk that we see
cognitive approaches worrying about as
well
so he goes on and he says that this is
the superego is representing the claims
of morality
we realize all at once our moral sense
of guilt
is now notice what he says here he
doesn't say it is
just the super ego he says it is the
expression of the tension between the
super ego
and the ego you have to have both of
those
poles in order to feel that that moral
guilt or there has to be a conflict
between them or the ego has to be the
prey
of the super ego so a lot of what we
call morality
is really just the super ego telling us
you know
we're we're screwing up or we'd better
not screw up and we're going to pay the
price if we
we do interestingly what is the price
that we're going to pay it's the super
ego being the super
ego and uh you know telling us things
that we don't want to hear so
the melancholic has to deal with this
periodically
in fits all of us go through this if
freud is correct at certain times
and then he talks about how the
melancholic you know might be free of
the superego
for a while and then kind of goes hog
wild and does whatever they
they want to do now he also talks about
this is a very important point the super
ego emerging
through as he says um
here we go the the installation of the
super superego can be described
as the success successful instance of
identification
with the parental agency now what is he
talking about is the parental agency
while the parents play a role in that
caretakers we could
we could say and we're going to talk
about this separately
and explore it in greater detail but
it's enough to say that
it comes from parents expressing things
to us which then the child
takes in internalizes
also looks you know at the the parents
as ideals
and the other figures can come in as
well freud talks about
school teachers and other authority
figures playing a role and we get this
internalized
agency of the the superego
who you might say is the successor
to the parental function the parental
agency
he also talks about another thing this
is what we come back to now this this
ideal
thing right he says that the super ego
is um here we go i hope you've already
formed an impression the hypothesis of
the superego really describes a
structural relation
and is not merely a personification of
some such abstraction as that of
conscience
one important function remains to be
mentioned which we attribute to this
super ego
it is also the vehicle of the ego
ideal by which the ego
measures itself right so there there's a
using the superego on the part of the
ego to make sure that it's doing the
right things
that it's living up to you might say its
potential right
he says it also emulates it so there's
there's a
important role for the ego ideal there
as well
and he says and whose demand for ever
greater perfection
it strives to fulfill
isn't that interesting so the superego
this is one of the problems with it the
super ego is never content
it never lets you just
fulfill its requirements after you've
fulfilled its requirements it
it moves the as we say moves the goal
post a little bit further
and says oh you know you could be this
good well you can be
this good then instead or at least
you've avoided being
bad in this sense now let's avoid it
over
here and so it's never truly
satisfied he goes on and he says there's
no doubt this ego ideal is the
precipitate of the old picture of the
parents the expression of admiration for
the perfection which the child
attributed to them and you know the idea
is that the child has a wrong headed
view but
that's what that what they take in it
becomes an important part of their
their psyche and so you know he talks
about
the superego as these are his own terms
the
representative of
every moral restriction the advocate
of a striving for towards perfection
he says it is in short as much as we've
been able to grasp psychologically
what's described as the higher
side of human life so
you know having a superego is kind of
good in some respects
not just because it keeps you out of
trouble but this this is actually a
um you know facet of human development
and he points out something really
interesting here
it's not just our own super ego
that we're taking cues from where did
the parents where did the educators
where did the authority figures
get their ideas about how they ought to
form and shape and guide and punish and
reward
us from their own super egos
they were themselves being driven by
the same sort of dynamics that we
have and and there's a really
interesting discussion here that i'll
look at
in a different point so he says a child
superego is in fact constructed on the
model not of its parents but of its
parents
super ego the contents which fill it are
the same
and it becomes the vehicle of tradition
and of all the time resisting judgments
of value which have propagated
themselves in this manner from
generation to generation
this generates what freud calls
ideologies
and he says ideologies come to take on a
life of their own precisely because
they are being handed down that's what a
tradition is you hand on
something to somebody else
so you're handing on this rather
contingent but
appearing to be absolutely necessary
feature of what we would attribute to
human nature it also involves group
dynamics he says
a little bit later when i when i made
use of the differentiation between the
ego and superego and
study of group psychology i arrived at a
formula that a psychological group is a
collection of individuals who have
introduced the same
person into their super ego and on the
basis of this they have identified
themselves with one another in their ego
and he talks about this is this is for
groups that have a
a leader right and so he thinks that
this is a
very important and useful
concept for making sense out of what
goes on within our
personalities and our psychical life
you